hey what's up guys my name is econo
welcome back to my game engine
series so last time we talked about the
entity class definitely check out that
video if you haven't already
today we're going to be continuing on
with the whole entity component system
situation and i specifically want to
actually start off with looking through
the pull requests that have come in
since the last episode since there are
some things to note there
but more or less today i want to take a
look at the camera class and just in
general talk about how camera systems
and all that stuff are going to work in
hazel so let's do the fancy a little
i don't even know if that worked did it
work yeah it did
fancy a little transition i finally got
a shortcut for that so i shouldn't be um
i shouldn't be having to click over here
and do the fade and all of that stuff
so what we're looking at over here is
fork which is my favorite
little git client and this is just
showing us the latest pull requests that
have come in
uh since the last episode so there were
some things that i don't really want to
talk about so there's like you know some
instrumental fixes sure whatever we
don't really
use that at least i don't think that
that code gets compiled like at all at
the moment
um this is a really nice change uh which
i'll probably end up discussing at
at length in an episode um maybe even of
the cpl plus series
because scd-bind and std function are
not really
particularly good things to use uh it's
a lot better to use a lambda and that's
exactly what this is doing
um and it's being a little bit more
flexible without but just you know
basically doing decal type auto and all
that stuff so that we
can deduce the return type um
after the actual uh lambda is declared
and all of that so we we will talk about
this stuff
in the future so that's a really good uh
fix by momo
hashtag momo
and uh finally though this is what i
really wanted to mention and this is
important
so last time i talked about when we
actually made the entity class and we
did this entity handle we initialized it
with
zero however what we should have
initialized it is um
with is null so if we pop back into the
code and take a look at the
entity class um
then we have uh let's see yeah so this
used to be initialized with
zero now apparently um
and i mean i should have probably done
my research like it got to the point
where like the creator of
entity actually told me himself um null
is
what you're supposed to use zero is not
what you're supposed to use because zero
is a valid entity so in other words zero
is a valid entity id
i don't know why i assumed it wasn't to
be honest i was just kind of like in the
in the heat of the moment i just decided
that it was um
that it was like it was like zero would
be like no entity i didn't
even know why because in retrospect i do
actually know that it's it's zero is
valid
but anyway point is that and null is
what you should use
to initialize this entity if you
specifically want it to be nothing
this isn't particularly necessary i
would say if i had to really scrutinize
this which i don't want to do
i don't think it's particularly
necessary for
this class um just because
uh you know i don't think we'll even
though we can create an entity
like this most of the time when we
create an entity
it won't it'll be with a handle and a
scene i
almost think that it might be worth
deleting this default constructor and
not allowing that to happen
the reason why i haven't is because um
is because when we create collections of
entities like a vector
and we resize that vector it would be
nice to just construct it and we need to
initialize it with something if we do
that
i mean we could leave that memory
uninitialized that's another option
i'm not even sure what happens if we
just do this um
like i don't know if that's going to
maybe we should check that out
actually um i don't know if i want to
i don't know if i want to take a look at
all of this code again though because
it's going to take me half an hour to
find out
how that actually like what actually
maps to and what that's initialized with
with the default constructor and all of
that
um but anyway uh regardless of all of
that
um you know that that's also a debatable
thing that we might talk about in the
future
okay um i don't want to spend too much
time on this i've said that a hundred
times already and the reason is that
this like in general you know working
with this stuff and talking about all
the
possible little things that we could do
differently is going to
be an endless thing and this video is
not even about that
so moral of the story is use null
use and null for um for
like non-valid entities okay
cool so let's do a quick compile and
make sure everything builds because i
just did the pull and i'm not sure if
everything works
so um here we have our green square like
last time
and uh yeah i mean everything works
obviously good so basically i mean
everything would have worked anyway just
me i just had to make sure the code
compiled after
after pulling the pull requests in okay
so now we're getting to the real meat of
this episode and what i actually want to
talk about
um is the whole camera system so if we
go to editor layer
i believe we're rendering everything
over here
um so we have the whole resize system i
want to
we might revisit resizing a little bit
more just because this was also a pull
request
and it's probably not done the way that
i would do it
um and i think i have a better way of
doing it so we might also revisit that
so this is what happens when you're
building this game engine and it's
getting complicated there's just so many
things to do
um but let's try and stay focused
specifically on the camera component so
how
how cameras going to work um i also want
to uh
probably get rid of hazel from this
entire class
um because we shouldn't really be using
that namespace here
so at the moment how do our cameras work
i think we just render so we do begin
scene with a camera that's important oh
well at the moment we're doing all of
our rendering in here so we probably
need to
okay let's let's do this because there's
so much stuff to do and i'm getting a
little bit
sidelined here let's just make a
structure let's call it camera component
i'll try and zoom in for all of you
people complaining
we'll do camera
camera camera i'll just stick a
namespace here so it's not ambiguous
and we'll include so where is this hazel
renderer camera right orthographic
camera is that all we have at the moment
what is i guess we don't have
a camera class do we
no we've we just have orthographic
camera this is probably something we
should also talk about
because um at the moment cameras
yeah okay and this is specifically
another okay
well we don't support perspective
cameras yet so yeah this does become a
little bit easier
um than i thought it would be but that's
okay so this is the core of the camera
uh component obviously the actual camera
itself um
we also have a camera controller but
this is like a camera controller is
something that is obviously more of a
system
and um even though we probably like
honestly speaking this is something that
i would probably implement within a
script
right so hazel's camera controller like
for the editor layer
that can definitely be a class and all
of that stuff and also
again if you're a level editor you're
not a game runtime
you probably wouldn't have a camera
component like you wouldn't have the
editor camera
going through a camera component the
camera would be like a
you know an intrinsic system to the
actual editor application
you know it wouldn't be part of like the
ecs um
where the camera is part of dcs is
during runtime so when we have a game
and we
are playing that game then most likely
the camera component
or rather there is an entity which is
the camera which has like a transform
which defines where that camera is
and also a camera component which
probably has the camera itself
that's also why this whole situation is
a little bit weird because this
this has a projection matrix of u matrix
whereas
tech and a position you know and all of
that stuff whereas technically
none of that's really supposed to be
there because you're supposed to take
that stuff from the transform
so long story short camera components
are quite complicated um in the sense
that like implementing well
okay quite complicated meaning they're
actually the opposite of complicated
they're really sparse and simple and i
think we will actually make that
here so what we'll do is we'll have a
camera
i'll make a new file just to kind of
demonstrate how this is going to work
namespace hazel and basically what this
camera is going to be
is just a projection matrix so matt for
projection matrix oh we'll just call it
projection will be
will be nice and simple okay so
um projection we can set this up well
let's just again we'll keep this simple
we'll just be able to create one with a
projection
here um again note that there's nothing
about this that implies orthographic
perspective anything like that right
this is it can be at this point it can
be anything
um and really the important thing for us
is to retrieve
the projection so get projection const
return
projection right that's kind of it you
know and
again to keep this even simple i think i
might just implement it here
that's really all we need um for a
camera class
because the view matrix remember the
view matrix what is that that's the
rotation of that
like the orientation of the camera and
the actual translation or position
of the camera in our world that's what
the view matrix is
um and that's not something that comes
from within the camera because that's
based on its transform
so this is kind of like a runtime camera
for a game engine it's
literally this simple and like the thing
is as as we progress you know we'll
whoops
as we'll progress um with this series
we'll probably have more functions
such as like you know set uh you know
set perspective or like set ortho
or orthographic or something like that
that will actually modify this
projection just with some kind of
just with a cleaner api than having to
go through glm and do all of that stuff
but for now we'll keep it really simple
so this camera
is actually something that i want to
have inside the component
so if we go to components um we'll
change this to just be a hazel camera
now
uh we'll include hazel renderer i think
it wasn't in i think it's in hazel
camera
probably should move that to the
renderer in fact let's do that now
before i forget
so where's camera
camera camera camera here it is camera.h
renderer and again we'll probably have a
cpp file for it in the future but
right now it's it's this
and uh let's see we're including
render a camera now and uh
i think that's okay this should work
right i mean i didn't move it
i always have to make sure that actually
moved successfully but i'm sure it did
um yeah and then this is kind of like
we'll just copy this
you know um we'll make it we'll take in
like a projection
so that we can just create a camera
component with like
with some kind of projection um to keep
it nice and simple
camera projection
camera component all right it looks
pretty good to me
um i don't yeah intellisense is being a
bit
upset at me as usual
okay so now that we've done this um
again this becomes pretty easy
we'll go back to edit a layout we'll
make a little um
we don't really need to do this
technically but let's do it anyway
let's uh make an entity here called
camera
camera entity and i'm being really
explicit here i'm specifying that it
actually is an entity just so that it's
easy to read this code
um all right so uh
we'll say camera entity equals active
scene create
entity camera
um also called camera entity again just
to be explicit camera entity dot
add component so it already has a
transform so we just need to add a
camera component to it
um and then the camera component will of
course take in a matte
sorry a orthographic projection let's
take a look at the one that we were
using
just because it's most likely right um i
mean we were giving this to camera
controller and i think that was creating
something
uh so and obviously like this
still needs to handle resize events and
all that so there is a little bit more
work to do
and in fact we did have functions like
set projection on the orthographic
camera
but that was specifically for like that
set projection whereas we probably won't
set
orthographic or set perspective and
functions like that but
uh yeah okay i'm not going to care about
this um
let's go back to editor layer and just
say that we want to
make this an orthographic projection
let's just do 16 16 negative nine
nine something like that and i guess
we'll do near and far as well
okay really simple stuff here just uh
basically setting it to
just an arbitrary 16 by nine kind of
orthographic projection just to see if
it works
and that's it so now now our scene
actually has a camera i do want to add
one more thing this is a little bit of a
another useful thing to have for a
camera um and that is whether or not
it's your primary camera so basically
what we want to do what is going on here
i see this i hate intellisense
anyway um whether or not it's your
primary camera and again this this is
something that is implemented in a wide
variety of ways like this could actually
be something the scene
takes care of instead of it being on the
camera component but basically what this
allows you to do
is any camera that is set the web
primary is actually set to true
um and i'm actually now i'm actually
contemplating whether or not this is
we'll do it this way for now and in the
future we might change it so the scene
is actually and the system is
responsible for this
rather than the camera itself but
basically uh it's possible to have
multiple cameras in your scene obviously
and you may want to switch between them
based on something so what you can do is
only have one camera
activate at a time and primary can be
set to true
if primary set it true then on like
multiple cameras then whatever happens
to be the last camera that's the one
that you render through
but obviously there's a lot more there's
many more options that you could
actually have with cameras
such as render targets and like you know
other complex behaviors potentially
um so this is like you know something
that you may not want to have on the
component but
we'll just we'll have it here for now um
maybe i'll i don't know if i should set
it to true or false obviously if you
could connect
uh create multiple cameras you'll have
to set it to false
um uh yourself which might be annoying
so maybe i'll just do this
and then but this is annoying because
now i have to do like you know dot
primary equals true or something like
that which is weird um
so i guess we all said it's true but
yeah this is like to do
think about moving to scene
so our camera has uh and we don't even
have to have that obviously
for now but it's just going to be a
little bit annoying to actually see
um to find out how we want to render
stuff if that's not the case
okay so guess what now what happens is
this when we
when we want to render so this is like
our render code render scene
we're under 2d scene render 2d
um well this may be render 2d sprites or
something like that sprites r2d so
render
whatever um so now that we have a camera
in the scene potentially
right the first thing is actually uh
trying to get it so we can just do
registry
um dot get or rather registry dot
view let's do view um camera component
so now we have a view for camera
components and we can actually look at
all of them if we want to so let's do
auto entity view right and i like to
usually i like to
scrape these up just so i can use like
the view um uh
variable name for everything but we'll
do
this and let's do
so we definitely have an entity now we
can also do view dot
get
[Music]
let's see i guess we need the transform
so we'll get the transform as well
from here
this will be the transform component of
the camera
we might as well just get the
um the transform
uh maybe i'm using this wrong what is
get return
get should get us this component but i'm
not sure if we can do that
because see with group you could use get
but with you maybe you can't
i don't know um obviously i could just
do uh yeah sorry i should be sorry i
should be doing
well actually i'm not even sure this
will definitely work or i just forget
but maybe you can get it from a
more narrow point of view i'm not sure
that wasn't compiling for me for some
reason
or at least intellisense doesn't like it
static concession failed
uh because
get on a view i guess entity type
um is same so it has to be the same
as what what on earth
okay let's do
let's just register again so we have
transform we have
uh i also need to get
okay this is silly let me just double
check let's let's try and find
the answer documentation because i'm
fairly sure that we should be able to
get that stuff
so let's move this here now i'm going to
be super bright because this is very
white
um let's take a look at the
entity component system um
where are views views and groups views
registry.view blah blah and then
interview no you can use
view get what's so why was that being
all sad
maybe it's because i was no i'm not sure
if that was the case
let's go back let's do view dot get
maybe let's not do that
huh but why is it transform.camera
i'm getting a transform component
uh i think i understand why
it's because i have to put it in here
don't i
then what's the differ okay yeah so
let's let's take a look at this
okay so groups offer a faster
alternative to multi-component views
although you can use multi-component
views
okay well that's okay so basically we
should use a group
so if you yeah view is something that
you want to use if you're using one
component as far as i understand
and a group is what you want to use if
you need to get multiple components
so what we'll do is basically the same
as what we did here
right um it's just that we'll get
transform and camera
this becomes a group and we go through
the
camera component and the transform
component
like that i guess we can do that
just so that it matches our bottom thing
okay
there we go so that that should be the
best way to do that using ants
although of course as usual i am not
sure
all right so at this stage now um
let's uh try and render this so really
the thing that we need to do
is find the main camera so if camera
and this i guess we can look at the
first one because i guess it shouldn't
matter
so this is the camera component um if
camera
dot primary then we found the camera
so what do i want to do well most likely
we'll do it here i guess shouldn't
really matter
uh let's do it up here
so we'll have a camera we'll try and
find the camera
oops we'll do this
main camera
what is it
what that's the components that's why
that's what we want okay
so um this is what we'll do
we're basically trying to find the main
camera in the scene if it exists then we
can do rendering right so if
main camera then we can render stuff
if not then there's no point rendering
anything because our scene doesn't
contain a camera
so if we haven't if we have a camera now
um let's uh
let's begin rendering so if we come back
to edit a layer for reference
we can see that we have
this we have begins in so we can do a
begin scene
with the main camera just like that
um except that takes an orthographic
camera in which is a bit annoying
um okay we'll probably change this api
quite a bit
but let's make it take a regular camera
in
um and we'll add a to do to remove
the hazel renderer camera
um so okay so but the thing is um and
this is where it gets really interesting
um we
most likely like when you actually
render though you need to know the
transform
so is it like do we really want to
um then create like a mount for that is
the transform
which is like the view matrix
probably not um so because of that
we're actually going to do something
else
this camera is uh essentially a camera
component
right and we might refactor the names a
little a little bit here
um but what we want to actually
have is a renderable camera
and a renderer kind of camera is a
camera that has a projection and a view
matrix because we definitely need both
of those
whereas this is more or less like
i don't know how to how to set this is
more or less like
the camera component kind of because it
it's
it doesn't include the transform it
doesn't include the view matrix because
that that lies in another component
and obviously we want it to work with
another component um
so yeah we we ultimately uh
we ultimately have this kind of problem
here where we might want
to have just this camera inside a
component
and obviously like you could argue that
well you know what
why don't you just go to components and
just have a
glm mat 4 here which is your transformer
sorry which is your projection
right you could do that but the problem
is you lose a lot of like
you lose the actual camera right a lot
of the stuff that the camera class
provides such as like get projection or
like
you know um you know set perspective
with certain parameters you lose all of
that and it's nice to have that
functionality
so uh that's why like it's it
yeah you know it's a little bit annoying
and you could put that functionality on
camera component but as a component it's
not really supposed to have
functionality like that
um so ultimately speaking i think what
i'll do is
we'll have camera but then also what i
want to do
is each render up potentially and this
this again this is probably
going to be shared between the 3d
renderer and the 2d renderer so it's a
bit annoying
but ultimately this might have a struct
called camera
right and this specific camera struct
and we can call this
um like render camera or something like
that i don't know this will have
um a um and you know this is just one
way of doing this that i'm showing you
uh not sure if i'll stick to this either
but we have a projection and we have a
view matrix now the reason this isn't
great potentially
is because if you have to construct this
every time you begin seeing which isn't
that often so it's probably okay
you need to copy the matrix here um type
finding your way into this is probably
not a good way to go especially because
you're not going to have enough room for
the view
um but you know that's ultimately it's
one way that you could look at this you
could begin a scene where the camera and
then some kind of view matrix and then
uh that way the api would look something
like this
where you could basically just go back
to scene
and just say begin scene you know
here's my main camera gear projection
and then
here's my transform right which we also
need to save by the way
um and then that way you begin it like
that that's something that you could do
you know um i've seen that i've seen
that as well
but what we'll do i think is we will
take in a camera like this but
i think the best way right now is also
to try and take in
a transform so we have a camera and we
have the cameras transform
this is not a view matrix it is the
camera's transform so we have to invert
it but
that's what we have okay so we'll just
do it this way
and let's create an implementation for
it
we'll do it this way and this will be
largely the same as this
um you know we set the view projection
here so we'll have to set that up
we do some texture binding here you know
again we will remove this stuff so let's
copy it for now
um and then what we'll do is we
basically need to
get the uh so glm metaphor
view proj equals camera dot get
projection times glm inverse
transform all right this should give us
the camera's view projection matrix
or the the projectionview matrix
technically all right and then we can
set that
that's it so back in scene
instead of doing all this we just do
this
um and we have a glm at four
transform
let's see
thank you for the arrow which no one
asked for
um okay uh and then transform to
transform
[Music]
um
this is upset again what's the transform
component
that has a transform in it which is a
matte four
so why why are you upset
what type is this
it's a mat four
what stressful ah sorry
i just um i'm using variable names
and of course transform is dumb i don't
know why i decided it's called like that
camera transform
okay so we've got the transform we've
got the camera
uh now we can actually pass that in here
and we should be good to go so now we
can begin a scene with our main camera
and then we'll do end scene as well um
render a 2d and scene and then obviously
in between that we render all of us all
of our stuff
and if there's no main camera we don't
need to render anything okay so there we
go
we should now be able to render
everything
if we have a main camera so render yeah
render
render 2d we'll just do render 2d all
right cool
so let's test this out
[Music]
let me just make sure that i guess we
probably won't render anything here so
let's get rid of begin scene so that
used to be camera control okay
so we won't be able to control the
camera obviously but now you can see all
we have here is
render command set clear color clear um
and then we just do on update and that's
it
so hopefully this will work
all right and we see our and 16 9 wasn't
the best
choice here because this isn't 169. but
you can see now we actually have our
green square and it's being rendered by
a camera
that is obviously our camera component
if we don't create the camera component
so i'll go ahead and not do the camera
entity then we it should still work but
we'll just see
like a dark grey screen with nothing
rendering i guess because there's no
camera
there we go um pretty simple uh
and uh i guess that's it so
that's our camera situation um again
there's a lot of different ways to do
this i want to stress that uh
i don't even like i don't particularly
like
all of the ways like everything about
the approach that i've chosen
uh if you guys have other suggestions
you can leave a comment below
um but uh so like
i don't think there's there's any real
big problems with this um
it will get a little bit different when
we start dealing with different render
passes
rendering to textures stuff like that
but ultimately this is more or less like
a main camera system
so if we have a camera that is marked as
the primary camera
then that's what it will be like as a
little quick
test though what we could do is create
multiple cameras so let's let's do this
as well
um we'll do m second camera
uh second camera will basically be the
same as this
except let's make it a little bit more
zoomed in or maybe let's
actually let's let's adjust this
transform i've completely forgot about
the camera's transform
um let's do this
second camera whoops hit something there
uh let's do like
um we'll make it like
minus one one minus one one so it's like
a little clip space camera
um clips face camera sure
um and then let's go back to
i am gooey man the font is so large it's
so hard to read
uh let's do so if
um if we had like i don't need to do
that let's just do
camera entity what so we'll adjust the
the first camera
cameras transform i don't even know if
we can do that well
i guess we can try um yeah this is not
gonna be pretty
um let's get that
okay let's do this let's do this um
i am gooey uh
floor drag floats three
camera transform
glm value pointer
that so we're getting we're getting the
last column of the matrix here
um and then fitting that in as a pointer
uh min and max speed one is fine min and
max if we
okay we can just leave that as is all
right um
and then we should now be able to move
that camera okay um and also we want to
switch between the cameras so let's do
this as well
um we'll do it we'll do a quick way
uh primary camera equals false
so this is just a little switch honestly
we're just going to display it as a
checkbox
so checkbox um label
uh
camera a i don't know um
and we'll make this uh the primary
camera
if that changes i basically want to so
let's probably initialize this to true
um so and then let's maybe uh come over
here to the second camera we have a
camera component here auto camera
component cc
um cc.primary equals false
uh so it's false by default and then
we'll just say that
m primary sorry m second camera
dot get components camera components
dot primary equals um
[Music]
not primary camera and then primary
camera
we do the same thing sorry it's called
camera entity isn't it
okay we'll flip that so basically we'll
be like you know if we've got i think if
i've done that right if we check
the checkbox we should be seeing our
primary camera which is the one whose
transform we can move
if not we'll be seeing the other camera
depending on what we actually
what we actually check or not so let's
take a look at
this we get a nice little crash here um
render api clear crashed
that's weird out of all the things i
would have expected this code to do
that was not one of them what on earth
happened there
did i do something let's just hit a
fight again that was weird
something to do with that frame buffer
huh let's see what's happening here
what what did i do
what did i do since the last time i ran
it i added an entity
which should be doing nothing
that almost seems like and it looks like
it's in a different place every time
what an interesting problem
so what's actually where's my output
what's actually happening
critical error detected oh no
critical error detected so this i mean
it suspiciously seems to be happening in
the opengl driver
this could be like some kind of weird
hip corruption or something like
that what what could i have done let's
do a rebuild i'm out of ideas
now it works
oh man okay weird it seems to work now
so i did a rebuild and it works
so let's roll with it um so
okay so we have this square obviously uh
we have the cameras transform as you can
see over here
right so we should be able to actually
move this and you can see that it does
work
if we move the camera to the left so
we're going negative here on the
x-axis it's obviously moving the camera
to the left because the square's moving
right
same with up and down and like zed like
that's not going to really do anything
because
it's just going to it's not the graphic
camera so we won't see it getting
smaller
okay so that's that's that and we we are
rendering with camera a now if we
uncheck this
we should be back to the clip space
camera which is camera b and of course
we can like move this somewhere else and
this
camera will always remain here okay so
now you can see we've got multiple
cameras we can render with both of them
and uh that is how you set up a little
camera system
in the entity component uh system
anyway thank you guys for watching hope
you enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button you
can also help support the series by
going to patreon.com
and getting access to hazeldev code as
well as
uh weekly live streams where i develop
all the code so if you want to see like
a camera system actually implemented or
anything really that we cover here
but in a lot more depth and you just you
thirst for more game engine series
episodes then
do check that out because the weekly
live streams i think are a really good
time
and by the way this episode was entirely
streamed live on twitter tv
the channel is something i'm playing
around with so if you're interested in
that
definitely check out the link in
description i didn't really announce it
anywhere apart from twitter so you can
also follow me there
if you want to catch the next stream
anyway i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you